[Music]
gaming's greatest strategy and tactics
experts have teamed up with the world's
greatest storytellers to create a new
aaa experience unlike anything before it
welcome
to marvel's midnight suns
this new tactical rpg from firaxis is
set in the darker side of the marvel
universe packed with a deeply
customizable tactical battle system that
rewards clever thinking with superhero
flair
an epic supernatural story that brings
you face to face against the demonic
forces of the underworld a deep
role-playing experience where you get to
live among marvel legends and the first
customizable original hero from the
marvel universe
as darkness falls rise up with the
midnight suns and face off against an
ancient prophecy foretelling the end of
the world
after centuries of sleep
lilith mother of demons has been revived
by hydra through a twist of dark magic
and science
lilith will stop at nothing to fulfill
the prophecy of the midnight sun and
bring back her evil master kathan
alongside her is her army of lilith
demonic forces who carry out her twisted
will with fanatical devotion
[Music]
pushed to the brink by her return the
avengers desperately revive a dark power
of their own the hunter a legendary hero
forsaken child of lilith and the only
one known to have beaten lilith before
in marvel's midnight suns the player
takes on the role of this new hero who
until recently lay peacefully in a
centuries-long sleep tucked away in a
quiet crypt on the grounds of the abbey
the secret headquarters of an
organization known only as the midnight
suns
for the first time in any marvel game
the hunter is a customizable original
superhero allowing you to live out your
very own marvel adventure
but you won't be alone marvel's midnight
sons features a legendary collection of
heroes that span across the marvel
universe including the avengers x-men
runaways and more
you'll see these heroes in a new light
as you develop relationships and
strengthen your personal bonds outside
the field of battle every hero has a
completely unique set of abilities
ranging from damage dealing attacks to
life-saving skills to epic game-changing
finishers
there are tons of unique costumes to
unlock
skills to upgrade and heroic team-ups
that unleash devastating combo moves
with your superhero squad picked it's
time to start fighting back the forces
of lilith
combat in marvel's midnight suns is a
cinematic tactical affair that rewards
clever thinking with superhero flair
the player controls a squad of three
heroes and is dealt a random selection
of hero abilities like a hand of cards
these abilities offer a vast array of
tactical choices that expand
exponentially when combined with the
battlefield itself
shove leap and smash your way to victory
using the environment to wreak havoc on
your enemies
send the bad guys face first into a wall
into each other or just right over the
edge
victory requires a balance of smart
tactical thinking and being able to read
and react off the battlefield as well as
cultivating your friendships outside of
combat and finding the right
combinations of heroes and abilities
battles rage across iconic marvel
locations like avengers tower to dr
strange's sanctum sanctorum from new
york city rooftops to underground hydra
installations
from sun bleached deserts to a hellscape
dimension far beyond our own
when the fighting is done the heroes
return to the abbey a living hub that
the player navigates in real time
experiencing for the first time in any
marvel game what it's like to not just
fight alongside beloved marvel heroes
but to live alongside them as well
the abbey offers hours of rewarding
exploration gameplay and story for the
player to enjoy
there's even a few lovable if unique
pets
get to know your favorite marvel heroes
through careful conversation and shared
time together through daily activities
take a stroll with tony stark on the
abbey grounds
or practice meditative yoga with magic
the choice is yours but choose wisely
because every hero has their own
preferences
developing deep friendships can unlock
powerful rewards in combat and in the
abbey
use the spoils of battle to earn new
abilities for your heroes down in the
forge
upgrade current hero abilities out in
the yard under blade's watchful eye find
new hero ops and missions in the war
room with captain marvel and much much
more when ready it's time to choose a
new mission choose your squad of heroes
and return to battle
the enemy may grow more powerful with
every fight but the hunter and the
heroes will rise in power to meet them
because that's what true heroes do
nice job out there kid i mean i didn't
get hydra bombed until my 10th run with
the avengers
kid
you do know that i'm a good three
centuries older than you right
[Music]
how long was i in that crypt
[Music]
no more than a few centuries
[Music]
centuries
and what of lilith
fallen by your hand
until now
you were
missed whatever caretaker put you
through back in the day did a real
number on you i know where the sun rises
we got a lot of work to do
[Music]
of course
caretaker has reformed the midnight suns
about time
you're a midnight son now one of us
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's blood on the horizon
but i don't break a sweat
cause i know where the sun rises
and i know
where the sun sits
[Music]
let me guess
stealth not your style
i'm a vampire remember
we invented stealth
you